[Music]
we have watched and listened from the
mountains we have watched with disgust
as your technological advancements have
enormous in my shadow
I've loved seeing like people reenacting
scenes you know I've loved of the mbaku
challenge
I've loved seeing like this very young
boy enacting the entire scene flipping
back between Winston and Forrest I mean
it was like that sort of stuff is just
gorgeous to me but yeah I think there's
been so many so much creative stuff
going on but I think that that kind of
seeing young kids like really absorb and
be able to reenact flawlessly the very
Cadence's of what they watched has been
really fun yeah it's just been a really
a beautiful experience I mean it was
just nothing you could ever dream of or
imagine happening so you know the the
experience you have the response it's
there's been from people of how they you
know embrace it and how they embrace us
wherever we go and and the the really
beautiful thing is the way people you
know thank us you know for it which is
just more than you could ever have
dreamt of receiving is is that type of
gratitude it just makes us have more
gratitude so it's it's actually been I
can't even put it so I'm in the dream
category because it's past that like I
didn't even dream of this happening you
know it's just something you couldn't
have even imagined so it's really
beautiful
[Music]